and I'm not like a trend Chaser too much
but same with the white claw [__] if you
get it right before it breaks you you're
the first to break it I mean you sorry
to interrupt the white claw thing for
people who don't know Trevor and I
remember you telling me about this I
knew him I knew you threw him for years
before he met correct but Trevor when
white claws was popping he had made a
shirt that said there are no laws ain't
no laws when you're drinking claws ain't
no laws when you're drinking claws it
sold crazy video that you made and and
they Su him stupid ceas and deist he had
to stop selling the shirts immediately
give back all the money I made Z yeah
they're piece but then apparently his
his profile I heard you say on another
podcast went crazy after that like it it
was it was like a catch 22 I don't even
know what that means but I think it was
but it one of those where like so they
saw the video and then they're like
let's talk Wednesday to talk about a
potential brand deal right and I go all
right cool but the video's boom right
now I'm a [__] I'm a business guy I'm
like 25 at this point I'm just hopped up
on ad I'm like let's get these t-shirts
out right I had a guy alter the logo
slightly put it up on sale Monday
morning and it sold like 7,000 t-shirts
in like 48 Hours yep there it is that's
probably out a [__] mkey ask in West
Palm Beach right now but yo this is this
is still everywhere dude everywhere
people have that tattooed on that yeah
people people have I'd say I've seen at
least how did you know and again this is
this I spoke to Gabe asking him things
about you and he said Trevor is
brilliant at knowing when a trend like
what's going to be v he's really good at
that I also think I'm sorry to cut you
off dude I also think the other piece of
your Genius though is to pick things
that are so nuanced that I don't think
people make videos on but I so you can
be original still it's yes it's it's
originality but also it's like this
thing where like the how do I say this
like you pick a thing that like that
seems nuanced but everyone goes oh no I
relate to that but it's like such a
small thing but everyone still relates
to the specificity specificity in com is
always F it's always a specificity
specificity in com is always funny if
you go like I was bang the chick a
restaurant that's whatever you go I was
banging chicken a Buffalo Wild Wings
that like the specificity of it is so
funny and your videos are very specific
exactly so like I did videos about like
guys who drive Subaru that could have
just been guys who are mountain men
nature guys but it's like it's too broad
but you define it it's like how is this
how somebody going to tag their friend
in this and like dude this is you or
this is Deborah who drives this [__]
right so it's like it's getting that
angle the White Cloud one was random I
made an hour and a half with my friend
Chad at I was living at home at his
apartment and uh that was a random one
and then I was literally I'm just so
half my shit's written half it's Rift
and I was like what rhymes with law uh
with claws what [__] take a letter
off laws yeah I just said that and that
just hit and that was all the quotes in
the videos and I can always that's what
I do for my videos if I'll do like a
seven five minute video or whatever and
then what to post on the one minute I'll
just be like what are people commenting
cuz that's that's what's the most
popular a five minute yeah and then I
let the people comment what they [__]
with you know I'm crowdsourcing
essentially yeah and then I be like okay
cool these are the top comments these
quotes these are clearly the funniest
because people uploaded it and then I
make that one minute but then everybody
was quoting that so I put that t-shirt
out and the shirt was like a funny just
because the so you made a full video
that line happened to be in it what was
the full video about it was just guys
who drink whiteclaw it was it was just
one of things it was just like not guys
who drink seltzer or but they were just
everywhere it was like my roommate uh
right before I moved back home for like
a month he was just like this my one of
my best friends Jason he's just like a
just a guy just a Golden Retriever with
a Zin in
his but like when he he was like my like
barometer of like what is like trendy
cuzz he'd be like so pumped on he be
like I [__] love spike ball I love
Hydro flash I love white claw and I'm
just like you are like America as a
person so if he [__] with it I know
it's Global you know so he was like my
barometer on that so he show me white
Claus I just made the video pumped it
out and then it went crazy and I sold
those t-shirts Monday morning to Tuesday
it went crazy literally it had like
$100,000 in sales but it was a print on
demand so so I hadn't made a doll yet
but it was racking up racking up and
then whiteclaw reached out with their
legal team and they're like Hey listen
we know that you haven't sent these to
the printer yet so if you you know
return this and you cancel right now
we'll talk about money on Wednesday to
talk about a potential brand deal and
then on Wednesday they go we don't think
this is going to be a good fit I got
[__] duped wow in the most [__]
which I don't think I've talked about a
lot is they came in they said we'll
return all the t-shirts but if you want
we can take all since you have the
emails of everybody who bought a t-shirt
we can send them official whiteclaw
merch like don't [__] use me as your
billboard yeah and also they're going to
take those emails for marketing like for
all their own I hate them as a company
they're terrible dude this I was at the
airport recently two people came up to
me that work for whitecloud like can we
take a selfie and I was like I don't
like you guys did you say no I said no I
said I do not like you guys I said I do
not like you guys your company's I mean
these people were younger so I think
that they weren't around during that
part of because this was like four years
ago that part of the company history but
I was like you're a terrible company
yeah like you [__] me over and I put
you guys so far on the map yeah and also
the asking for everybody's email bothers
me that's the key it was that it was
that it was like Hey we're going to take
all that we're going to take your
customers and give them just Official
White CLA merch it's like that's not
funny nobody wants to wear just a white
CLA t-shirt they wanted to wear it cuz
it was a joke on it and they probably
wouldn't even sent them [__] they just
wanted the emails that's where I'm
grossed out by bro the but my ticket
sales after that were crazy that's when
I really started selling yeah is it I
was doing like one nighters and then
that happened I had my first weekend in
[__] Rochester and it was sold out
comary Carls whatever and I was like oh
[__] that's that video did things so
everybody in his audience has white
claws clubs will be like dude what is
wrong with your audience we went through
like [__] five pallet of this [__]
like cool give me a cut of that too no
but I will say it's like that part
sucked but looking at the bright side it
just brought awareness to me so like at
the end of the day I'm happy with it for
w not to use you as a as like their
spokesperson is crazy dumb but maybe
that's good it get maybe it's because
then because then it's like maybe you
don't want to be like just pigeon
holding just that yeah it worked out for
you but they're done these people don't
get it these these big companies they
don't yeah their photos are all like in
like black and white like film Noir like
people drinking I'm like you don't
understand your audience your audience
like butt chugs it like an FSU tail like
this is not K off a skateboard you're
like doing a [__] black and white
yeah think it worked up talking about it
but I do think overall it helped me grow
so much so the end of the day if you
still want to sponsor
me did you always have that sense or was
that all death because travel Alex you
know you remember all def digital huge
YouTube channel the only white employee
they had I was there Jim Jim Carry
essentially from uh like Living Color
right yeah when you brought on his
calender brought on as like an editor I
was a social their social media intern
and then they knew I did stand up but it
was kind of like all right and then
slowly over time it was like all right
you going to have one line in the sketch
all right then you have two oh oh [__]
all right let's get this guy in a in an
unscripted thing let see how it is so
it's was like a slow Progressive thing
but then they started putting me in a
bunch of thing and then I just be kind
of became like a cast member but I was
on full-time salary doing social media
seen sorry for those you who haven't
seen all def it's great if you ever go
to watch roast me that is like yeah if
you're watching from YouTube you know
roast me like that is like like watching
that live like that is hands down the
funniest people I've ever seen in my
life but yeah so so I I got it was like
the best job I think could have had out
of college CU I just working with all
comedians like Doughboy who was also
wilding out Kevin on stage to more tony
Baker just all like very very funny on
and off stage yeah because I was I was a
fan of Kevin on stage and like I saw you
before I knew who you were you know
because of those Kev said I texted Kevin
about you he said I'm the first guy that
probably took TR on the road my first
road show I did we did Tennessee State
University and only white guy there for
quite some time but he was
so like
he took a moment and looked in the
middle
distance but was [__] up was we were
driving through these gigs and we we're
driving through like Kentucky and they
see a Confederate flag they look at me
I'm like don't [__] look at me those
are my people dude hey also stop I need
to say what's up is my uncle but yeah he
was the first guy to take me on the road
and they were doing one nighters man one
was in the comic Club one was in a
church uh I love those guys I am so
thankful for that you think those guys
helped you a lot uh with your business
sense of things so you have a very very
like clean business sense just yeah I
mean it's it's yeah I think so because I
I would see Kev on stage go do one NS on
a weekend do Friday Saturday Sunday and
then be in the office Monday morning and
I'm like you [__] took a red eyee
from nework and now you're still at work
like Andy had two kids and I ask him
like how do you do this he goes I got
two kids and a wife I got to feed people
you know I got to like keep it going and
just seeing that work ethic and hustle
and he was still he bro Kevin on stage
is the hardest working man I've ever met
in my life he records videos he's a
business genius I think oh my god when
we used to work at all this digital he
record videos in his car right just like
put it on like a magnet and then he
would just rant about whatever's going
on in the news like he was talking about
the the J stuff something he would rant
on it for 5 minutes get in the office
cut it down to 30 seconds it' be up on
everything before I'd be even at work
crazy and I mean the GU just he and like
seeing him in uh traveling in airports
with him back in the day because I only
knew it from work we' go to lunch a few
people like oh Kev Kev in the airport
everyone's like [__] Kev I so it was so
cool to see and I was like that's my
mentor and everything like he is a
genius and I so I think to that point
yes they definitely showed me like the
the way and I remember the day I put my
uh quit I was like how much money do you
have uh saved up Kev cuz he was leaving
too and he told me he goes how much do
you have and I told him he's like oh bro
[__] leave what are you doing here
still what were the numbers uh he said
he saved up like 60k to leave and I had
20,000 in the bank so I was starting to
get a little bit of YouTube money and I
was very very very little starting to
get paid for standup I was I think I had
like 20,000 my overhead was 800 bucks I
was living in Santa Monica three bedroom
apartment he got two kids it's a
different thing bringing it back to Will
and J on stage and Mrs Kev on stage who
I've never met in person but watching
them that's what I wish will and J was
where like their book is called marriage
be hard they met when they were both 15
yeah met when they were 15 still seem
very in love but never front and act
like they're perfect yeah what happened
I miss
some with 15 so
hot is hooking you up with UFC tickets
if you're lucky uh okay all right guys
we're going to take a break real quick
because Morgan and Morgan might make
your dreams come true if you're a UFC
fan first of all you already know Morgan
and Morgan America's largest injury Law
Firm recovered over $5 billion for their
clients and we know submitting an injury
claim with Morgan and Morgan is free and
super easy but did you know that they
are also the official injury Law Firm
partner of the UFC you don't believe me
well check this out UFC 296 coming in
hotter than anything You' Ever Seen
Crazy card Morgan Mor has giving you a
chance to watch it live they're going
give one lucky winner two free tickets
to UFC 296 to see Edwards versus
Covington and $2,000 you get tickets to
an event in Vegas and you get $2,000 to
gamble with entering to win is easy just
text flagrant to four that's the number
four the people again that is 484 373
6753 and when you do that you get a
chance to win $2,000 and two tickets to
UFC 296 in Las Vegas again text flagrant
to for the people again that's 484 373
6753 also I have to say this no Pur
necessary open of 4 continuous United
States NDC 18 plus the sweep stat ends
November 2023 ENT official rules visit
Morgan UFC 296 sweep ppa.com now let's
get back to the show all right guys
we're going to take a break real quick
because I got to let you know about
vessie shoes let me tell you something I
swear to God I have them on right now I
had to come back the day after we
recorded to do these dads and it was
raining and I was walking so I put on my
vessis they are 100% waterproof and you
don't have to buy ugly ass [__] rain
boots you still get to wear fashionable
shoes and they're 100% waterproof if you
don't believe me check out their new
sneaker called the Soho fire as [__]
100% waterproof you ever seen a shoe
that looks cool and is waterproof
probably not probably not these do it
vessie Soho if you don't want to wear
clunky ass rain boots wear your vessis
they are truly super comfortable able I
walk like 3 miles in them just now you
know what else is great if they get
dirty mine are a little dirty they're in
the rain you know I'm going to do
tonight throw them in the washer I think
about it come out 100% clean and
spotless so if you're like me and you
want to be ready for anything rain or
shine head to vessie dcom flagrant and
get yourself a pair today and if you use
the code flagrant you will get 15% off
your entire purchase and you get free
shipping to Canada us. Australia Japan
Taiwan Korea and Singapore let's get
back to the show you guys want to drink
oh this is another thing blow I never
did [__] when we were homies forever can
we about this yeah yeah yeah ran got me
high for the first time great first time
ever high ever I took a Delta one time
and it wasn't like I was fully high but
then with Rogan I was like I've already
done Delta eight so let's just smoke
weed and when he gave me a little
pressure I was like yeah I'm not that
opposed to it and I think my main fear
was always I don't trust my work ethic
if I start getting high all the time
especially but now I'm like I know I'm
going to bust my ass so I can get high
every once in a while I still don't
drink but if you want to drunk Blau is
the best dude can I tell you a story
about drunk Blau we got drunk after a
show he did in his hometown I forgot
about this and then afterward Blau gets
drunk he's celebrating it was me Schultz
and Blau and Blau headline had a [__]
ball whatever great show great audience
and then Blau gets drunk and then we go
to like some random [__] Diner and then
blau's drunk and he keeps standing up
from the diner table and going excuse me
ladies and gentlemen I have an
announcement who who was trying to get
fingers what city is this in DC that's a
normal night in DC you miss the best
part there's a diner I'm not let's say a
100 people I stand up and I make them
all shut up it's 2 in the morning I go
guys guys please please everyone please
I have announc can you please stop just
real quick would you have the glass in
the
night essentially I was like who is
trying to get finger and I did it like
twice yeah no he did it three or four
times and one guy to fight gu tried to
fight cuz he just got you know guys get
jealous when they like go out and [__]
and this guy's getting attention so he
is so funny because he was such a [__]
about it he was talking [__] to Blau and
me and another comic who was little and
then Andrew's there and then blau's
friend who's a Big Country Strong
[__] were there and he was like
no you two are cool but these three I
got problem I said [__] the whole time
I'm looking the other way but then BL
stands up and he's like yo bro you are
so [__] ugly
dude goto to talk [__] to a guy is
you're so I wouldn't even finger you
dude we almost fought we used to get in
almost fights all the time and that was
the first one I was like this boy drunk
is wild oh [__] I forgot about that
you're so [__] ugly like in his
you're so that doesn't make him pissed
off doing on purp so mad but he also
bl's homie you could tell he like loved
fight he was like oh yeah I don't want
to fight but if we do I'm going to en
enjoy beating the [__] Perfect combo cuz
you were talking [__] and he defend and
I can tell this is like a college
Dynamic of this literally you learn to
go walk around with the c with a
[__] around with a
giant this dude and m mcor i it's my
homie I [__] love him so I had I had
two I had three your agent funny that's
probably where I got the name yeah is
where you got the name um but in college
dud I was the same thing I talk hella of
[__] but I had like three big friends
who love to fight this one story where
we got we all got in a fight and when I
say all I mean them um and I was always
a dude that waited and then kicked
[__] in the head like when I
was yeah yeah and I'll just I'll be that
guy I felt Blitz him 100% And we were we
were all getting fight of this bar and
we all got [__] uh pepper sprayed
from security dude have you guys ever
been pepper sprayed in the face had to
use a cop was a cop dude we were lit we
were literally spitting on each other's
faces you like that though and I came
pull my ha I came real fast and I I
remember we were
spitting just to get anything out and we
were one of my buddies Argo I love him
so much he literally he was taking the
spit and going like this and he couldn't
get he was like B he's so country what
the [__] I can't believe you
[__] [__] with with his friend
spit and then he just takes his head and
starts to run it on the cement dog he's
making he's drunk as [__] he he's pepper
spray drunk with my spit in his face
rubbing his face on the [__]
literally cutting his face cuz he thatch
hilarious but he's trying to do anything
to get it out security gos are just
laughing look at these idiots dude bunch
of cockroaches with raid on
them dude that's so funny it hurts so
bad but that was when the guy was like
ready to fight that kid mccor Chris
what's his name Matt M Matt stood up and
he was like hey man I don't think we
need to do this and then the guy backed
off so hard like they they just wanted
to pick on people they thought they
could beat up and the second there was a
guy that could clearly kick the [__] out
of them they're like no it's all good
but it was so funny to see drunk BL I
Love Drunk BL he's he's my favorite
person also guys I'm not going to waste
time talking sports with these two
because they don't know nothing about it
so if you didn't know I had been on an
unbelievable cold streak on price picks
we're going to keep it going you know
the plan you pick the exact opposite of
what I suggest and that's going to make
you money also you sign up at price.com
and use the promo code schs they will
match your initial deposit up to $100 so
if you invest a 100 you deposit 100 you
get 100 for free it's h you really can't
lose unless you're me and then you find
a way to lose every week but that's how
you win just pick the opposite of me